Este es probablemente el vídeo que más
nos habéis pedido y al mismo tiempo, tal
vez, el más complejo de todos los que
hemos abordado. Tras 52 años de
enfrentamientos
el conflicto entre las Fuerzas Armadas
Revolucionarias de Colombia, conocidas
como las FARC, y el Gobierno colombiano
ha llegado virtualmente a su fin, a las 00
horas del pasado 29 de agosto de 2016.
Para quienes no las conozcan, las FARC
son una guerrilla de corte marxista
leninista, que desde su fundación, hace
ya más de medio siglo, han sembrado el
terror por toda Colombia. - "Un invento
maquiavélico desgarró la vida de 119
personas, 42 de ellas niños. Un cilindro
bomba del grupo terrorista de las FARC
buscaban impactar a grupos paramilitares,
pero los inocentes pagaron la afrenta."
Hablamos de la guerrilla más importante
de un país donde la mayoría de sus
habitantes nunca han conocido a la paz.
Precisamente, hace poco tuve la
oportunidad estar en Colombia y si algo
me quedo claro es que es muy difícil
encontrar siquiera una familia que no
haya sido afectada por este terrible
escenario. La herencia de las FARC y
demás grupos guerrilleros como ELN,
el M-19 o las Autodefensas Unidas de
Colombia, ponen los pelos de punta:
a lo largo de estos años se han
producido27.000 secuestros,
25.000 personas continúan aún
desaparecidos y más de 220 mil
colombianos han perdido la vida. -"Los
soldados se quedaron sin palabras cuando
comprobaron que uno de sus enemigos era apenas un niño."
Además, cerca de seis millones de
personas fueron forzadas a abandonar sus
tierras y sus casas.
Y a todo ello hay que añadir, claro, el
continuo ataque a la infraestructura
de todo tipo, oleoductos, puentes,
ferrocarriles... Un horror, vaya.
Llegar a un acuerdo no ha sido en absoluto una tarea
sencilla,
de hecho ya existieron dos grandes
intentos que fueron liderados
respectivamente por los presidentes
Belisario Betancur, a mediados de los
años 80, y Andrés Pastrana en torno al
año 2000. Fue precisamente a partir de
este segundo intento fallido cuando se
puso en marcha el llamado Plan Colombia
un acuerdo colaboración con EEUU,
impulsado por Bill Clinton, por el cual
el Tío Sam aportaba cada año ingentes
recursos para la lucha contra
el narcotráfico. -" Cuando conseguía sólo
una señal no sabías a quién escuchabas.
Por eso entonces el gobierno
estadounidense desarrolló un programa
que podía identificar las voces de
nuestros objetivos."
¡Ojo! Las diferentes de guerrillas se convirtieron con el paso del tiempo en
poderosos cárteles de la droga.
Así, se estima que, por ejemplo, tan sólo
las FARC consiguen facturar cada año
más de 600 millones de dólares con los
narcóticos.
- "Incluso después de haber pagado a sus
guerrilleros, las FARC tenían activos
por valor de 10.500 millones de dólares
en 2012." Bien, a pesar de lo que podría
parecernos, el acuerdo de paz está
polarizando la sociedad colombiana y el
apoyo al mismo no es ni mucho menos unánime. Para explicar esta paradójica
situación tenemos que analizar cómo se
ha desarrollado la negociación.
Así pues:
En primer lugar, la doctrina para la
seguridad democrática y la estrategia
de mano dura puesta en marcha por el
anterior presidente, Álvaro Uribe, junto
al Plan Colombia de los Estados Unidos,
le causaron un daño importantísimo
a las FACR, que veían cómo día a día
sus fuerzas eran diezmadas.
De hecho, en poco tiempo, las fuerzas de
seguridad colombianas acabaron con la
vida de importantes dirigentes de la
organización, como fue el caso por
ejemplo de Raúl Reyes, Mono Jojoy o
Alfonso Cano.
Además, el cada vez mayor uso de
tecnologías como los drones y los
seguimientos por satélite, hacen hoy muy
difícil esconderse con lo que se puede
decir que la suerte está prácticamente
echada. En segundo lugar, el régimen
chavista demostró que era posible y
más efectivo hacerse con el poder
mediante estrategias políticas y, por
cierto, si algo tenían las FARC era
dinero para lograrlo.
¿Por qué estar en la selva corriendo el
riesgo de ser bombardeados, si se puede
conquistar el poder desde cómodos despachos?
Además, con el apoyo y el asesoramiento
de los amigos chavistas.
Pues, lo cierto, es que el papel de Santos
ha sido muy controvertido, tanto que
incluso apoyando su iniciativa de
impulsar las negociaciones para la paz,
no me veo capaz de defender bajo ninguna
perspectiva la estrategia que ha seguido
durante el proceso. Su incomprensión por
los problemas que comenzaba a padecer la
banda y su empeño por obtener un
histórico éxito político llevó las
negociaciones por unos derroteros
sorprendentes. En primer lugar, redujo la
presión del ejército y las fuerzas del
orden sobre los guerrilleros de tal forma
que, claro, según todas las estimaciones
disponibles el negocio de la droga, tanto
a nivel de cultivo como de producción y
distribución ha repuntado muchísimo
los últimos años,
fortaleciendo con ello la posición de
las FARC. -"La guerrilla de las farc
continúa vinculada al narcotráfico
pese a las negociaciones de paz con el
Gobierno de Colombia, lo denuncia el jefe
de la policía antinarcóticos del país.
Segundo, aceptó negociar sin que las
farc hubiesen suspendido siguiera sus
operaciones criminales,
de tal forma que durante la negociación
esta panda de criminales acabó con la
vida de más de 1.500 policías y
militares. ¿Negociar amistosamente
mientras esos salvajes cometen semejante
barbarie? Es de locos.
Tercero, no fijó ningún plazo límite
para la negociación, de tal forma que lo
que tenía que haber durado meses duró
años. Y es que esta posición era muy
cómoda para los jefes de la guerrilla,
que estaban cómodamente instalados en
la Habana, disfrutando del clima y los
encantos caribeños, seguían haciendo
mucho dinero con sus actividades
delictivas y encima podían
reorganizarse.
Por si fuese poco, la negociación era
conocida y, además, se desarrollaba en
Cuba bajo el cobijo del régimen
castrista, lo que en definitiva
suponía más presión para el Gobierno
Colombiano. -"No se puede olvidar la
importancia vital de este gesto nuestro
para el arribo
al feliz puerto del acuerdo final." Es decir, Juan Manuel Santos hizo todo lo contrario de lo que
se supone que hay que hacer en una
situación así,
y, claro, estas cosas luego se notan
en el resultado.
Pues, básicamente, lo es porque buena parte del pueblo colombiano entiende que los miembros de las FARC
han obtenido demasiadas prebendas, es
decir, demasiadas concesiones.
Hay quien considera que incluso el
gobierno ha llegado a faltar al respeto
a la memoria de todas las víctimas.
- "Cuando uno pide perdón es porque se
arrepintió de haber hecho algo, yo no me
estoy arrepintiendo de haber hecho lo
que haya hecho.
El documento final tiene casi
trescientas páginas, con lo que os
podéis imaginar que únicamente
podremos destacar, y de una forma sintética,
las cuestiones más relevantes.
De hecho, la primera parte del acuerdo de
paz se centra en políticas agrícolas y
rurales. ¡Tal cual! El gobierno de Colombia
ha consensuado un programa político con
el grupo terrorista, un programa además, muy escorado a la izquierda que contempla: - "Las
Zonas de Reserva Campesina se han
convertido en áreas del control del
terrorismo." Y casi lo que es peor, en
el futuro no se podría modificar.
En segundo lugar, el acuerdo no exige
arrepentimiento y, además, contempla, en
la práctica, la impunidad por todos los
crímenes, incluidos los delitos de
sangre y narcotráfico.
En esta línea, para aquellos que
confiesen crímenes contra la humanidad
no habrá penas de cárcel, sino penas
alternativas dictadas por un tribunal
especial, donde la propia banda estará,
en cierto modo, representada.
Tercero, se contempla la transformación de la guerrilla en un partido político que
tendrá ¡ojo! incluso reservados cinco
asientos en el senado y cinco asientos
en la cámara de representantes, que
podrán ser elegidos a dedo.
Además de crearse dieciséis nuevas circunscripciones especiales que, por supuesto,
estarán bajo control de la banda.
Cuarto, los líderes de las FARC no
tendrán que pagar indemnización alguna
a las víctimas y podrán conservar
intactas la inmensa fortuna acumulada
mediante la extorsión y el
narcotráfico.
El estado pagará por ellos a las
víctimas. Quinto, los más de siete mil
guerrilleros que forman la organización
recibirán un importantes subsidios del
gobierno para facilitar su tránsito a
la vida civil. Así, algunos cálculos
estiman en torno a los 275 millones de
pesos, unos 90.000 dólares
estadounidenses, el dinero que le
costará a la hacienda pública cada
guerrillero. Así, por todo ello, no nos
puede resultar extraño que un acuerdo
de paz, llamado a hacer historia, sea tan
polémico. Y que figuras tan relevantes como
los expresidentes Álvaro Uribe y
Andrés Pastrana se opongan
fervientemente a él.
- "Esto no es un acuerdo, esto es un sometimiento del estado a las propuestas del grupo narcoterrorista FARC."
Y es que no resulta nada sencillo.
Por un lado, está el loable deseo de
alcanzar la paz de una vez por todas, por
otro lado evitar que quienes han causado
tanto dolor se acaben saliendo con la
suya y condicionen por décadas la
sociedad y la política colombiana.
Personalmente me encanta Colombia: sus
gentes, sus paisajes, su alegría, y espero,
de verdad, que en poco tiempo este bello
país se vea libre de la violencia para
siempre.
¿Qué pensáis vosotros? ¿Es bueno el
acuerdo de paz? ¿Ha conseguido Juan Manuel
Santos el acuerdo que Colombia merece?
Seguiremos de cerca todas las novedades
y muy pronto hablaremos más de Colombia,
entre otras cosas comentaremos el cambio
de tendencia económica que está
registrando el país. Para seguirlo con
nosotros no te olvides de suscribirte al
canal. Por cierto, el pasado viernes os
dejamos un mensaje en nuestras cuentas de
Facebook y Twitter. Como aun sois muchos los
que no nos seguís por ahí, aprovechó
para invitaros a verlos y de paso seguirnos en ambas redes, donde iremos
compartiendo nuevos materiales
diferentes a los de YouYube.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.